We've now discussed and
created a feature where a user can
limit their housing search results
to be within a specific travel time of
a point that they care about, like work.
However, how can we
give them more details?
Users don't just want to know how long
it will take them to get somewhere,
they also care about
how they'll get there.
If I'm taking a subway to work every
day, I want to know that I'm not
going to have to switch trains
three times, take a ferry, or
maybe I want to see multiple options for
routes in case the service goes down.
Luckily, we have the ability to get and
show the user the information they need
about how they would travel
from their potential new home.
The directions API,
much like the distance matrix API,
gives us information about a journey.
However, instead of just the time and
duration, it provides step-by-step
directions from point A to point B, and
even to point C through Z if needed.
Many of the same inputs can be used.
The travel mode of either driving,
walking, bicycling or transit.
Multiple transit modes such as bus or
train, and
restrictions such as avoiding tolls,
highways, or ferries.
Directions can specify origins,
destinations, and
way points as either text strings.
For example, Chicago or Sydney, or
as latitude-longitude coordinates.
The directions API can return multi-port
directions using a series of way points
or via points.
We'll demonstrate their request and
response, again,
through a web service
request within the browser.
So once again,
we have the same URL route.
We're using the direction
service this time, and
we're specifying we want
our output in JSON format.
Now, we need the required parameters.
For directions API, we need a single
origin and destination pair.
We can make them specific
like lat long coordinates, or
very general like cities,
which would use then the city center.
Finally, you need your API key.
Before we look at the response,
let's talk about other possible
inputs to this request.
This particular request would default
the show as driving directions
from the center of Brooklyn to
Google New York City office.
As with before,
we can optionally add in a travel
mode and a bunch of other things.
The instructor notes has a link to our
documentation with a more complete list.
Let's set our mode to transit since I'm
probably going to take the subway or
bus to work.
When I'm using transit, again,
I can specify the transit mode.
For example, subway.
I can also specify the transit
routing preference
whether I want less transfers,
less walking, etc.
I usually choose less walking contrary
to many of my Fitbit wearing friends.
We can also again use bicycling so
that we have a scenic
bike ride to the office.
But if I do that,
I'm going to want to stop along the way.
Luckily, I can add multiple waypoints.
Let's say I wanted to stop
off at my favorite bakery,
then continue on to work.
I can use the waypoints parameter to
specify an additional destination,
which is taken into account
as a stop in my route.
Alternatively, if I just wanted
to pass by and smell the bakery,
I can specify via instead of waypoints.
And then my root wont consider an extra
leg, it'll just take me by the place.
So let's execute this request and
see what kind of stuff we get back.
First, I'm going to execute my transit
route with my subway specified and
less walking specified.
As with the rest of these service
requests, we get a status.
Okay is the one we want.
If the request would fail,
the status would not be okay, and
you wouldn't see a route
in your response.
Next, we'll see the geocoded waypoints.
This is essentially taking our origin,
destination, and
any additional waypoints and
making sure the service was able to
successfully find that location.
It gives us the lat longs as well.
We only see two points here
since we had no waypoints.
This is our origin and our destination.
The next thing we'll see
is the root data itself.
So let's expand this.
There will only be one leg if you
didn't specify any waypoints, but
the root will be split into multiple
legs if you did specify waypoints.
Each leg has a duration and a distance,
and a start and end location.
Each leg also has one or
more steps, a step being
the smallest unit of instruction.
For example,
walk to Kingston- Throop Avenue.
Each step also has a distance and
a duration, so
there's some very granular data here.
Each leg also has an overview polyline.
This is what will allow us to
display the root in our map.
Finally, we see any warnings.
For example, if there's no walking or
biking path,
and you specified bicycling,
the response will tell you that.
Let's execute our biking
request with the waypoint
to see the difference in their response.
So the first thing you'll notice is that
we have three geocoded waypoints here.
One for origin, one for destination,
and one for our waypoint.
We also have two legs,
unlike last time where we had one leg.
The first leg here will be from
our origin to our waypoint,
which is Tompkin Square Bagels,
by the way, it's delicious.
The second leg will be from
the bakery to my office.
As we talk about going from
point A to point B and
making stops along the way, it sounds a
lot like the traveling salesman problem
where he has to plan his journey to
cover a number of different clients
at different locations in
the most efficient way.
The good news is the directions
API can do that for you, too.
Here, we'll execute walking
directions using three waypoints.
Notice that they're pipe
delimited in this request.
The response will have four legs, and
the order of the points isn't the order
we specify them in the request.
But you can add in the optimized true
prefix when you specify waypoints.
What this does is it
will do the planning for
you to cover all the stops
in the most optimized way.
This means that the result may change
the order of the waypoints from how you
originally provided them in the request.
Notice now, the order is different.
Our first address was 350 5th Ave,
but our first stop is actually
going to be 165 Avenue A.
It's optimized it for us.